Terry McLaren it's what he's got to work  with in Washington he's always getting  the opponent's number one cornerback  Taylor heinecke roller coaster I think  we saw a better version last week than  we necessarily should expect I will be  sitting bears are implied to score a  weak low 16.5 points I gotta be sitting  David Daryl Henderson first game this  year without Cam makers I do wonder how  much longer Daryl Henderson is going to  have this role so I would not be afraid  to sell high on him at all I will be  setting him Brandon Cooks is an  interesting spot this week he is on the  trade block I'm not thinking of the  trade situation as a positive Brandon  Cooks will be a sit for me Trevor  Lawrence he's in London brutal match up  so to sit Trevor Lawrence